but i gotta say
samsung
has really impressed me with this and no
one's paying me to say that folks
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
what's up guys we are back with another
s22 ultra video and this time we are
talking all about cameras we're gonna
run a lot of camera tests here there's
four cameras on this uh this phone got
two telephotos one wide one ultra wide
plus the video the ak video the 108
megapixel sensor in this the 100 times
zoom all that we're gonna test so let's
have some fun and let's go to chinatown
and test the low-light performance
because of course every camera looks
good outdoors in bright sunlight right
xenio exactly but when you go low light
how do these cameras perform against
light against to get that beautiful
bokeh we're gonna find out let's do it
now samsung's touting of course this new
snapdragon 8 gen 1 chipset is going to
really help boost the ai to really help
with low low-light performance
especially in portrait mode as well it's
going to separate the hairs they said
it's almost like using a real camera
we're going to find that out xeno's got
great hair zachy's got great hair as
well we're going to test the hair flip
the look of that see how that looks
against the bokeh balls just get all
these great lights here and then also
we're gonna see how video works in low
light because sometimes that's make or
break it for these smartphones how can
it handle video in dark situations let's
find out okay so we're gonna try
portrait mode first here with you know
we got these great lights in the
background now first thing you're seeing
here is this flaring that's coming in
from the lens this is something we're
seeing on a lot of smartphones these
days i mean they're touting all these
great camera capabilities but they can't
get the flaring under control so we'll
try to use this as more of an artistic
look here by just sort of placing the
camera ever so so much but uh give us a
shot hey can you bring down the mask
i mean i know you want to be zoro but
you know so we're going to see how this
separates the hair from the background
here
three
to let that umbrella people walk away
with the umbrella well you're giving me
blue steel man blue steel
one two three
one two
got it so right off the bat i have to
say it does a pretty good job looking at
the hair you are seeing some separation
from the hair and the background
at the one time
and of course you're gonna you can
adjust the bokeh on this to your liking
but i will say
you do notice the difference with the
telephoto lens it's a much softer more
more of a pastel color look to it but
when you go to the one times it's more
contrasty more punchy in color so there
is a difference
in the lens that the camera is using
which it would be optimal if actually
they were the both the same so you have
that continuity which you're not getting
here so i would say the main camera is
going to be your star camera usually is
on all smartphones but telephoto
different look you can you know edit it
to make it look the same but it doesn't
have that same punch let's try this with
this one let's try this one one more
time
very interesting here you can see the
strands of hair here and i'm going to
change the background effect here
because sometimes
we don't need it so
blurry
that's max
the intensity is down to nothing
there's a pretty good job i have to say
of maintaining the hair you're seeing a
little bit of hair there
pretty natural i mean it's not 100 but
it's a smartphone and that's ai kind of
coming into play versus using a proper
lens to get that depth of field so now
we're going to try the 108 megapixel
mode on this camera system now it's not
a true 108 megapixels no smartphone ever
is it's pixel binning but nonetheless
they do show some pretty outstanding
results when used correctly now we're
gonna try this on this uh temple here in
chinatown
beautiful in terms of the lighting right
here the details and the structure and
everything else so we're gonna try to
capture as much as we can
with this 108.
and then let's go to these lanterns come
here we're gonna try some low light
performance here
now this is pretty low light right here
okay this is you know if i want to shoot
anything darker than this but we're
gonna give this a shot see how this
looks
first impressions
the colors are just popping
off the screen
okay so first impressions off this 108
megapixel is that it's very very
detailed great noise control so you're
not seeing any sort of noise coming into
play great low light performance even
when you use the night mode that even
accentuates it even more
and it actually still looks quite
natural i mean it's got a little bit of
an hdr look to it as night remote does
but it still looks
really really good but the details that
i'm seeing on this screen are awesome
we're gonna see how this exposes for
this uh this is a dragon this is a
dragonzaki let's take this image here
wow the colors are just awesome
the details are insane off this camera
system and the fact that it can expose
it correctly is really good in terms of
the metering inside of this because some
camera phones have a harder time to
meter versus others this is nailing it
now of course i'll try all the different
lenses here
now that is at one times
point six
it's a little bit overexposed in certain
the light areas
now we're gonna get here in terms of the
flickering that up at times three
and then times ten
it clears up
ai is doing its magic sharpens up the
image
and it looks really good
all right it fixes it it corrected the
flicker
so inside of it actually corrects the
flicker which is great but the detail
i mean of course and these are not even
the main lens right
let's see how the ultra wide the ultra
wide might be the weakest of the four
cameras i see in terms of detail
lacking in detail a little bit
overexposed but again ultra wise they're
never they've never really been as good
as the other cameras for the most part
but i got to tell you this main camera
is
a powerhouse
i mean the ai the exposure the detail
uh the colors
and lower light situations of course the
telephoto lenses don't have the aperture
to really allow and allow that light in
so you're gonna see it's not as clear
not as sharp
but uh
i would say the sweet spot would be the
three times telephoto
zoom lens 10 times it's pushing it three
times is your sweet spot standard looks
great as we mentioned before and ultra
wide well
low light
might not be the one that you want to
use in low light unless you just want to
capture a scene but you're not worried
about detail that much so for this shot
i'm going to try some portrait modes
here to see how this looks try to
separate the tigers uh
you know the face from the rest out
there
once again
ai kicks in
really does separate your subject well
beautiful bokeh it looks very natural
this is the best samsung camera i've
used to date out of any of their phones
i'll to be honest with you uh one of the
reasons why i left android after a while
i went over to my iphone is i just found
the camera system in the iphones really
good and very consistent
but i gotta say
samsung
has really impressed me with this and no
one's paying me to say that folks this
is a very impressive camera
let's try pro photo mode on this because
i want to try to capture this but i'm
going to change the white balance a
little bit here because this is what you
can do
bring it down to adjust
crank down the shutter speed
very detailed the water droplets that
you're seeing here on the tiger's face
capture beautifully here now here's the
thing about pro photo mode it's great if
you want to capture some you know
interesting shots and you want more
control of your shutter your iso
etc etc
but it's not going to be the same as
using a professional camera system but
you can really accentuate some things if
you want to do that now for something
like this if i want to get that bokeh
because i'm using a camera smartphone
i'm just going to use the portrait mode
because i think to me that's the best of
the
of the lot here and it still maintains a
lot of detail a lot of portrait modes
lose detail
but it seems that the s22 ultra is
maintaining a lot of that detail in the
shot
let me just
bring that exposure down
nice
loving it loving it okay
all right what else to shoot man what
else to shoot what do you think let's do
low light video yeah load live video
let's go back to our corner here with
the lanterns and shoot some video how
about that
so far it seems really steady i got to
be honest with you i'm walking and i can
you know
obviously i'm not a
ninja walker here but it looks very
steady on
the screen
it is working well in terms of the
exposure because it is quite dark above
me but here
it does expose relatively well
aka 24p here we go
let's see how it does with low light
let's see zack and xeno right here again
the crop factor is
quite significant
so i'm guessing
either there's something going on or the
camera system or it's using another
uh
sensor in the body because
it seems that it changed lenses i'm not
too sure maybe maybe it's the same lens
i'm not
no idea
but uh
i mean the details are pretty good
i have to say for low light it's pretty
damn good i mean you are going to see
some noise creeping in on this uh
looking at this i mean obviously it is
quite pixelated once you get to some
lighting source like the lanterns above
me it does clean up a little bit but i'm
looking you can definitely see the noise
creeping in at ak24
on this camera system so uh again
not bad it's not going to be like a
professional camera system out there but
it does the job and we're going to shoot
video let's say in a club or a nightclub
or a bar
you'll get your image just don't expect
to be pin sharp like it is in broad
daylight it's not gonna happen but it
does a decent job
so now i want to talk about a feature
that is really good on this phone and it
is the mic
uh set up here so you can have omni mic
capture sound equally from all
directions front so if i'm let's say i'm
doing instagram story or tik tok and i'm
filming somebody here like this
gentleman or here's zacky right my voice
from the front of the phone is capturing
me then here's the rear so zacky talk
hello my name is zacky and i'm doing a
dance so you can hear him better than
you can hear me
then of course you have usb bluetooth
bluetooth mix
but this is great if you want to do ig
stories tick tock all that great stuff
something that other smartphones don't
have yet and i'm glad samsung's included
here it's only in the pro video mode
though so if you want to use this pro
video mode only
that's right
all right so for our last test we're
going to try the macro capabilities on
this because uh cameras touting macro
capabilities very similar to what the
iphone does
let's see how well it captures this
durian right here
wow that hurt
taking a look at the macro shots on the
screen i would say that
the images look a little bit pixelated
again there's ample light here so
it could just be
the ai maybe i need to see it on the
computer screen i don't know but first
impressions if we can compare macro mode
from the iphone to the s22 ultra i would
say the iphone
takes the lead on this but anyway
we're gonna go into lightroom but
before we do
well you really want me to get in there
zacky
fine
before we go into lightroom here's a
message from our sponsor here at geek
culture we love our keyboards especially
with the all new logitech mx keys mini
an elegant and functional keyboard its
ultra responsive rounded keycaps are
super stable and quiet for more
productivity there are buttons to enable
dictation microphone audio control and
emojis the backlit keys illuminate when
you get close and matches the lighting
of the environment you're in it lasts up
to 10 days on a full charge or 5 months
with the backlights turned off to find
out more about the logitech mx keys mini
and their latest range of products head
over to logitech.com
all right we are now in lightroom taking
a look at images here from the s22 ultra
took majority of the shots in low light
photography but also did some in sort of
overcast day because it's been a the
rainy season here in singapore let's
look at portrait mode here on
my volkswagen tiguan for a moment here
and i got to say this looked relatively
good this looks very natural for
portrait mode and i'll show you the
before edit then after edit before edit
after it again edits our personal
preference you may like or dislike but
let's just look into the uh the raw
image here or the jpeg without any edits
and you can see that there's a lot of
detail here you can see the water
droplets here and you see the nice fall
off that looks relatively natural
you know from the front of the tiguan to
the rear you see how it gradually just
goes out of focus and then to the
background here of course you can adjust
this into the phone to your liking but
it does look well
it does look good and let's just take a
look here again uh you have a little bit
of play with these files but it can look
a little bit crunchy if you uh overdo it
with the edit so just take that in mind
with any smartphone photography uh let's
look at another image here uh this is of
course was with the the t1 as well and
again a lot of nice detail here as well
this is before edit after edit before
edit and after edit but there's a lot of
detail you're seeing here and the
headlamps uh looks really good with the
water droplets here this is a very good
smartphone camera especially in ample
lighting now let's look at the
front-facing camera for a moment now
this is a picture of myself that i took
in the geek culture studio this has been
edited i will show you the before edit
here uh just to kind of go over the skin
tones it's got much more of a
i would say where the iphone is much
more of a warmer tone this has a more of
a cooler tone but it's more accurate i
feel than the iphone in this regard but
let me just show you what it looks like
after edit here and the nice thing i
like about is the details here around
the skin tone and the beard here right
here because this is something that
samsung always had a problem with with
their front-facing cameras previously is
even when you turned off beauty mode and
all the skin smoothing and everything
else there would be some sort of
softening happening but now they're
allowing the photographer or the owner
of the phone to actually you know
dictate what they want and if you want
the detail it's there for you and this
is a really
sharp picture for a front-facing camera
i mean i pop this on instagram or
facebook it looks great you're gonna see
a little bit of noise creeping in here
but again that's something that can be
reduced with uh you know lightroom or
luminar or you know topaz de noise but i
have to say i'm really impressed with
the detail coming out of this
front-facing camera
okay let's go to some portrait modes
here this was uh something we took of
zeno at
the chinatown area we've shown here in
the video already but here is the edited
version this is before edit and here's
after it again you can play around with
the files here there's some dynamic
range here but let's look a little bit
closer here at the hairs we're seeing
the nice separation and this is
something that samsung was touting with
these new uh
camera systems with the ai built into it
that it works better with portrait mode
and i have to say this is really pretty
accurate i mean if you were to use a you
know a normal camera you would get
something like this as well um again
getting a little bit of that flaring
coming into play this is something that
you know smartphones are having a hard
time with you know it's just part and
parcel with the way the lens is designed
but i mean if you use it correctly it
can be quite creative now let's look at
another shot here of the main camera to
show the difference now of course this
is gonna be high resolution the colors
are much more punchier as you can see
before edit and after edit but a lot of
play in the files and look at the detail
in his his shirt
his jacket here the backpack there's a
lot of detail here which is nice because
usually portrait mode you lose detail
because of all the ai coming into play
but samsung's done a pretty good job in
terms of maintaining detail but giving
that portrait uh you know that
background defocus so you can play with
that a little bit more okay now let's
look at the main camera here in terms of
low-light photography this has been
edited a little bit you can see that i
was focusing right here there's enough
detail here noise reduction is coming
into play but it looks relatively good
this is before edit and then here is
after edit
before edit and after edit this is what
the main camera very impressive for
lower light photography here is with
night mode all right
now you're going to see a little bit
more that hdr look coming into play here
as most night modes do but it does a
relatively decent job of maintaining
detail still with some decent dynamic
range this is before edit and then after
edit before edit after edit i always
recommend just kind of punching the
colors up to your liking with any sort
of photography out there because nothing
straight out of camera will look optimal
here's a great shot that i took with the
main camera just to kind of show you the
detail that it's able to capture even a
lower light photography of this uh
dragon head here look at how sharp this
is this looks absolutely fantastic with
the buildings in the background this is
with the main camera
uh here's before edit and here's after
edit before edit and after edit
absolutely love the uh the quality
coming out of this main camera this is
samsung's best cameras to date honestly
really really impressed with it and
here is
the uh three-time zoom as well so we
show this in the video but look at the
detail when you look up close this is
absolutely awesome and if you think this
is sort of
this is so if you think this is sort of
uh you know mushy here this of course is
a painted dragon so this is actually
what you're seeing it looks like almost
like watercolors because that's what it
looked like in person but the detail
there is really really stunning a couple
more shots here of these tigers portrait
mode look at the detail that we're
seeing here
the paint structure here the detail
through
the tiger's head and through the paws
and the legs absolutely awesome really
impressed with that
[Music]
and let's talk about black and white
photography because you can do this with
the filters in the s22 ultra with any of
the cameras and it's actually very
impressive so if you do like black and
white photography you're going to really
like what this camera provides again
you're not going to get as much noise
because of course just black and white
but i mean this is really really nice
very happy with the images that i got
out of this as well
look at the detail here very very
impressive i would say the black and
white gives you a little bit more detail
than even the color on that matter but
again black and white versus color
you're always going to get that okay
let's go into macro real quick because i
was talking about macro photography
and unfortunately as i mentioned it's
not as good as the iphone okay so uh
this is
yeah not good
a couple shots here i tried to zoom in
on this it's really pixelated folks so
while
i mean i think samsung tried to add this
macro capabilities it's not as good as
what the iphone is producing right now
maybe that'll improve with a firmware
update in the near future so anyway
those are some shots from lightroom
let's go back to my final thoughts
all right as we saw from lightroom the
image quality out of the s22 ultra is
very impressive for a smartphone
especially the main camera now the wide
angle lower light not so good in
brighter conditions it actually fares
quite decent the telephoto lenses the
three times to me is the sweet spot it's
still really sharp uh really good
clarity to the image 10 times is
struggling a little bit i'm not going to
do 100 times zoom honestly speaking we
tried it but it's not it's neither here
nor there it's more of a gimmick to me
than anything else you're never going to
use it uh but let's talk about video for
a second because this is where i also
think the ls22 ultra does really shine
8k only in good light but again would
you use 8k i don't know i think 4k 1080
is going to be the sweet spot for most
people even 1080 for the you know
because of instagram tick tock you can't
do 4k and that stuff yet right and
that's primarily how people are going to
use their smartphones for creating
content is in of that range but if you
are a professional videographer and you
do want to like a sort of a small b cam
i think the 4k will definitely suffice
in that regard the colors coming out of
the the sensors are great uh the clarity
uh the image quality is just is really
really good even for photography i mean
this is the best samsung camera system
i've seen on any of their phones to date
they've really done a great job with it
but this is still early in 2022 i mean
right now this is the king of the
smartphones in my personal opinion when
it comes to image quality i think
samsung's knocked it out of the park a
lot of the great features as i mentioned
the microphone option where you can
select which microphone you want the
front to the rear omni these are great
attributes to have especially for
content creators hopefully uh apple
answers this and other manufacturers do
this as well because it is a necessity
especially in our day and age and how we
shoot content but i have to say samsung
has done a tremendous job with this now
i know there's a lot of comparisons out
there with the iphone 13 pro max and of
course the s22 ultra we didn't want to
do that because
in my opinion the ecosystems are very
different you're not going to switch to
samsung if you're in the apple ecosystem
and vice versa if you are in the android
ecosystem you're not going to go to
iphone just because of the camera
i don't think you i may be wrong on this
but for me i believe the ecosystem is
much more than the camera itself it's in
terms of how you share your files in
terms of syncing with your other devices
all these things come into play and
that's why someone that's in the apple
ecosystem will have a harder time going
to android and vice versa but to each
throne i would love to hear from you
guys what are your thoughts on this
anyway like always subscribe to the
channel if you can like this video uh
follow us on facebook stay safe out
there and i'll chat to you soon take
care